[Musique]
tu est importante tu forte tu as de la
valeur qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici
quelqu'un a détruit ma maison où les
carl je crois que quelqu'un va revêtir
les vrais car la banque et de la région
a été kidnappé dans sa propre maison à
la suite de ce qui semble avoir été une
[ __ ] megan est dans la merde regard
des nouvelles
y at il un message que vous voudriez
transmettre au public je le salue tu es
là car je sais que je vais devoir au
maire dillon qui noté mon frère je crois
mon saisis chez le chercher madame bâton
d'habitude quand quelqu'un disparaît les
gens appellent la police avant d'appeler
les médias
il était un homme tellement charmant
pourquoi quelqu'un leur canapé poussines
photos de moi et kara là si jamais vous
en avez besoin pour toutes les
conférences de presse et qui aurait pu
pourtant d'une retraite non à le port
non nous les gens pas peur de toi je
peux pas te faire confiance pour
s'occuper de mes affaires si les gens
ont peur de toi là c'est la partie où
vous fait sauter la cervelle visiter mon
vagin train d'exploser d'alarmant je
respecte ton faut pas braquer des armes
sur les jambes car les pales genre à se
faire kidnapper c'est genre à laisser
tomber sa femme si toute cette histoire
de kidnapping fausses il faut que tu
dises soupe si tu as fait quelque chose
qui est ce moi ou précédées est ce que
vous avez peur quoi je suis
toc toc on a un cadavre je suis forte
et j'ai de la valeur j'ai par exemple
oui
un week end horreur un week-end de chaos
et de deuil pourrais tu s'il te plaît
blessés célébrer c'est une belle journée
c'est une belle journée tu trouves pas
fait non
[Musique]
julien fait mal je veux juste qu'ils le
relier à bessan je vous jure ces femmes
blanches sont folles